We are going to talk a bit about javascript
we are going to talk a bit about machine
learning and I am going to emphasize the
bit because I want to focus a bit
more on the process and what it takes to
learn both for one as an individual
and for the computer and  how
javascript has evolved from its
first appearances to where we have
arrived today and everything that
javascript allows us to do
then without further ado we talk about the beginning we
would like to first of
all establish the expectations about
this talk about what it is and what it
is not  In this talk I would like to clarify before
anything else that they are not in front of an
expert in machine learning they are not
a data scientist I am not a
mathematician I do not work in machine
learning I am passionate about
technology I really like learning and
the purpose of this  it is precisely
to land machine
learning to terms and concepts that
each and every one of us can
understand
so that we are not afraid to go into the
subject to see how easy it can be
for each and every one of us
to start talking about it  and not let
the subject overwhelm us, so
this is not a talk delivered by an
expert in the field to a mathematician, a
data scientist, it is not a session
where we are going to create and design our
own learning models, but I do hope it
will be a talk  where we are going to
learn a little about the
basic concepts about the first signs of
javascript in the subject and to play a little
to learn why not then it is the idea
of ​​this talk is to understand how far
javascript has advanced in the business what it
has done today  today the
basics of machine learning start
working with simple implementations
play a little with machine learning in
javascript and I repeat this talk
gives someone who is simply
passionate about the subject and
researches it a bit in his spare time at
night  I try
to learn a little about the subject and
share a little of this knowledge,
so that's what this
talk consists of. I think that something that causes a lot of
fear has already been the history of
javascript throughout all these
years, it is approximately 25 years old, I think.
that if we want to understand something we have to
know where it starts from and
as a fan of animated movies I
like to quote this this phrase or this
character if we want well we start from
an origin our end begins at an
origin and javascript starts from then on
from our first  indications when
netscape was cool, more than one of
you don't even know what netscape is
nowadays and internet explorer
was beginning to emerge as soon as i'm
talking to you 95-96 that in web development they are it's
a complete story go there
javascript began there were their
first pininos  and eventually
javascript today is
everywhere today we see javascript everywhere we
turn and we see it in
web development obviously we see it in
mobile application development we
see it in desktop application development
maybe many of you
don't even know that  they are using in their day
to day applications that were made in
javascript and very surely it continues
to be just as criticized and I repeat they do not
realize that they are using it in their
day to day communication for example
through is the one that in the development
through vision site with tools
that are made on the web and
we use them every day as
part of our see part of our
careers
on the server side obviously has
had an impressive boom in
recent years through the  night is
why not think that you already see a proposal
on the embedded side because not to think
that it is in the internet of things
this has already come to the farc we are
talking about that small library
or the small language that started the
script  online web that started
small validation of forms for up and
little by little it was gaining ground introducing
animations and burying flash
he mentioned actionscript and others
burying beach a while ago what it is today
that simply ceases to exist and how it
has continued to dominate the world  I'll see,
so that has evolved
until today, because
we use it for things that were previously
not even thought of as the subject of machine
learning in my opinion and not only a
fan of animated movies but
also marvel in my opinion, you
see nasri  Something like this guy that you see on the
screen, I would just like to clarify
who
the guy on the screen is talking about, the serum we are
talking about, because quoting from the
movie, we are talking about whether he is in the
right hands, if he is a
good person, he said, he is in the right hands.  It
becomes ten times better in the
wrong hands, it is ten times worse. You see,
being such a permissible language,
so permissible and that it has allowed and
evolved so much and has gained so much
ground,
it is precisely the
right hands in a good programmer, in a
good developer.  someone who takes care of
the language who takes care of the code who
takes care of good practices
eventually has a lot of potential and
I repeat because of how permissible a
language like javascript is in the
wrong hands of course it can
generate code that we don't feel
proud of but that's javascript  in
essence and that freedom is what has
allowed him to get to where he is today
and precisely the objective of this
talk is to discuss how javascript has reached
topics such as machine learning,
which is something that was not seen just a few years ago
come
then machine learning with javascript
before going into the topic the machine
learning line 2 I would like to talk a
little about machine learning which is how we
see it how we live it what we think
is how it feels how it looks and this
depends a lot on the context and  the
perspective that each person has, if we
see it as alien to the subject, it
will surely scare us to think about
the potential it has and the use it
has today of machine learning,
however, if we think about what it is, we will
see it as something  super complicated we are going
to see it as something that nobody understands and we are going to
see it as something that
revolutionizes the world two of these things
can be true
as non-technical people could imagine
is that we talk a lot about the
lawsuit of the fight that exists between  the
good and evil of the fight that exists
between dominating the world through
computers and I repeat, we could see it
thinking of a drastic scenario in
this way, however, we do not have to
be afraid of something and I
believe that fear comes from  not understanding
the issues of not understanding certain
certain aspects now I personally believe
that eventually there is some
destruction of the world that comes from
artificial intelligence night learning
others but not in the way you see
on the screen I think it has much more
More to do with the behavior of the
human being and how it has evolved
towards even modifying the way of
thinking of the human being, sometimes topics such as
inception, for example, that we later see
in movies and we don't know what we are
talking about,
think that they already put us into  ideas
through artificial intelligence
is not something that is alien to our day
is not something different from how but in
social networks today for example so it
is not a futuristic issue machine learning
is not a futuristic issue is a
current issue let's  see some exercises
that we can do our first
steps in the subject of machine learning
with javascript a little parenthesis
here because I understand that we have people in
the audience not only from mexico from
argentina from peru from colombia if
suddenly I use some word that is not
does it mean the same in my Spanish as it does in yours,
in advance an apology for
that machine learning is not something so
different from what we currently see on the
screen this is how it feels we are
teaching the computer to learn
as we learned in preschool
it is exactly  the same process we have
a data entry that is this and
we tell the machine that this is how the
jaw feels so the difference
between how it
looks and how it feels is abysmal my
goal in this talk is for all of us to
feel as simple  how you see it now on the
screen the first concepts the
learning process trying to
understand at such a basic level how
we are currently seeing it on the screen
let's think about our
learning process our
learning process is very is very simple we have
a question
we think about possible  scenarios or
possible solutions to this question
what we do is filter or define what
is that possible set of al khoms filter
what interests us we
identify patterns and begin to
integrate to see if our theory is
true or not depending on each new
input from  data that we are having in the
end what we do or when we say I have
learned is when different
situations I am able to determine
which is correct and which is not
that is my learning process and it is not
different from the learning process of
a computer
we are going to do a  small exercise I am going
to guide you through a small exercise
to validate that indeed the
learning process of a
computer is the same as the
learning process that I carry out in my day to day,
understand a new
programming language a new topic a new
language etc etc etc  So this
computer learning process is not going to
be different from the process that I am
following, which is what the
computer does anyway. We have a question and we are going to
try to solve it or to
answer it.
We are going to list possible solutions.
of data that we are interested
in to be able to identify patterns from
these we are going to alter between each
of the possible solutions to
identify these patterns that
we have and we are going to repeat each output
will be a new input of data
until eventually we have  a
solution that we feel comfortable with
until eventually we have
considered that we have learned if we
present this in a visual form that
is what we are doing we have a
raw data set a raw data set
eventually we filter to what
we are interested in  assuming
we want to learn about history let
's focus on a location
in 17 years between which years are
we going to start studying or trying to
learn that will become
our set of structured data they
are no longer raw data they are no longer events just for
or  Because there is now a set of
events filtered to our interest,
later we do an analysis,
we do an analysis, which leads us to
what is called a candidate model, which
means with what I know so
far, this would be if they ask me again,
this would be my  solution this
would be my answer this is a
candidate model it means that there is still
a lot of data that I have not processed and
eventually my answer or my model
can evolve or will change
the more data input I have
that is an interactive process it is a
cyclical process  we are learning and
each data input or each output of
a process becomes
data input towards our new cycle
until eventually with the appropriate number of
iterations this becomes
what is called a
golden model or a final model this model
end is the one that we already
feel comfortable with
and what we are going to do is connect
our applications to this model what we
are going to do is tell the
application
if I have this data input
eventually this is going to be my output and
feel comfortable with  This is with this
data output. I repeat, this is the
process in which a
computer learns, it is not different from the process in which
I learn, and in the
end, what the applications do is
connect and consume this data, we
are going to do this.  With a small
exercise we are going to learn
just as the computer would do what
the exercise will consist of. We have
a set of words. We are going to learn to
pronounce some words in English. I
am going to filter. I am going to focus.
We are going to filter words.  with the letter or
going back to the diagram we are processing
our raw data to only what
we are interested in I am not going to
focus on all the words in English we
simply have a filtered set of
words that begin with the letter or
that is my data my set  of filtered data
that is my area of ​​interest each iteration
or each new word will generate an
interaction in my cycle and what I am going to
do is define a model in each
round in each repetition in such a way
that I take the first the first
word  the first letter I hear a
pronunciation similar to a and then
I say ok the letter o is pronounced something
similar to a today a combined u I
understand then that the letter o is
pronounced in English as an out and that is
my model it is not a model  In the end, just
a single word came but that is my
model my candidate model in the first
iteration eventually there will be a
second word a second word that
says the letter o with the h ok I
pronounced it similar a show similar to the
pure letter or what does it mean  that my
model seems to be true it seems to be
correct the same model that I already had
in the previous iteration applies then
I understand
that the letter o is pronounced as a
combination of o with
something similar on out however we have
a third iteration of  such luck that
the letter o with the n will not be an out it will be
more an on closer to an app for
example then I assume o my new
model will say that if it is an o with an n it goes
between an o and an however anything
else will follow  being one or one u
because in those three iterations that is
what I know until then I am not
interested in the rest of the words I
have only learned in these three what it
means that if a fourth
word arrives I am going to try to answer it yes
to me  They tell me what the word
operation is, I am going to try to solve it or
pronounce it according to what I have
learned in the three previous words.
Eventually I will learn that operation
is not pronounced as much as nor on and as the
only way, so I have a new
model and about  I am learning this
until in the end as I have more
now I have more words and more words I have
an out and operation up surf and
each one of these gives me new data by
this I mean that in each
iteration the last output data
serves as  input data for the new
cycle to continue learning my
learning process is that simple I
take a new word I see how it is
pronounced I compare it with what I already
knew previously and I add it to my
catalog of words each
iteration I try to learn something  new
until finally I get to my
golden model when I already feel comfortable with
the rules in the end all I do is
get to my golden purple model and with
this
but I already feel comfortable with the output
in such a way that my applications  Now,
if you can come and consume this
golden model, when a sixth, seventh,
tenth word arrives, I'll feel comfortable
saying well, it's one or in conjunction with
a t and many other rules that I've
learned in the perfect process. I
predict or I can predict that  this
word is pronounced in such a way
this is the learning process of a
computer this is the
learning process that I follow in my day to
day and I am sure that it is the
learning model that most of
you follow when  I repeat, they want to learn
something, something new, whether it is a new
programming language, whether it is a new language,
etc., etc., etc. Now, and
this is a key word in
our learning process,
the models help us to predict, it
means that they have a percentage of error,
that is true.  what they do is with so much
data I think my way out or my
solution should be this way let's
win in social networks let's think of
one as a user how come how come
a facebook how come a twitter how come
a google gives us different
answers or different suggestions from
pouso different suggestions from friends
depending on where we are depending
on our last searches
depending on what we have done the day
before
without exaggeration almost almost depending on
what we eat the night before they help us
predict or they predict what
we are  It may be of interest on a certain day and
making a parenthesis to what
I mentioned this time and
artificial intelligence is not oblivious to what
we do in our day to day and because
the world is changing not so much thinking
about the image that it put on the screen
but because it is changing  the world because
people are inculcated with certain
ways of thinking, making us believe that they
are our own thoughts and that is
often not the case, which is what
they make predict in such an
accurate way what it is that is going
to interest us.  continuation depending
on searches that we have
recently made to the friends that we had
been seeing or reading in the last
minutes and other decisions how it works
I am sure that not even the creator of such a
model knows today how it is that how it
works
but the point of  all this is that what
a model does is predict predict as
close as possible the
next point or what is the solution to the
problem or the question that is being
presented to you a few weeks ago
surely more than one of you had the
opportunity to see a presentation
about neuro link and something that I would like to
highlight about said
presentation was when they share
images or explain how they implanted
a chip in different animals there were
three or four different pigs
that were implanted with these chips that to
begin with the simple simple process
between  In quotes, the simple process of
implanting a chip in the brain of a
living being and being able to extract it
satisfactorily without damaging it is already,
in my opinion, an amazing process,
but being able to extract information from
it through the nerve terminals
is still  beyond this and there will be
those who say is that implanting a chip
imagine now if implanting ideas and
putting thoughts of people who in
reality would never have had them now
if the term of inception can
apply and surely
all this will end there but but  I don't want
to focus now on the
write permission for me it is amazing to
just read data from the brain of a
living being just to read data and what they
explained in this presentation, what do you
see on the screen, this graph that
well represents what they did with  the
implanted chip was through the
nerve terminals they predicted what
movement the pig was going to have
where it was going to position one of its
legs in the following seconds and see
how it was going to be walking then
what is seen on the screen is each one  of the
legs where he was stepping exactly in
real time they presented it and where they had read
and where the prediction was made where it was
predicted that he was going to be stepping on and
each of the joints how is it
that if he is going to be flexing where he was going to
be positioned etc. then  what is
seen
is a prediction against what happened in
reality again let's forget about
reading thoughts in
a brain for the moment and think about the
applications that it could have, for
example, a person whose spine had
had some variation no no can not
cannot  a paraplegic person can walk,
but if he can or if he thinks about the
movements, why not think about creating
that connection, skip that vertebra
that does not allow linking of the
movement and continue the process so
that the legs
can eventually move with what
the terminals  Nervous had been
identifying to do a bypass of that
vertebra that does not work and
satisfactorily predict where
the leg should be or moving the
foot or or tilting flexing the
knee
then the pure implementations of
just thinking about reading the data
let's get rid of it for now
and embed thoughts in a person
because many people have already made this
type of comment the pure
applications of predicting something
like what we saw in this presentation
for me are already surprising enough
to see what continues in this branch
in  this technology this is something that
caught my attention in this
presentation and it is to emphasize
the issue of predictions again a
model does not guarantee the output of data
predicts what the output of data would be
with a given input of the same
now
to get to implementations there are
so many libraries in javascript and now
focusing on the subject there is one
that we have been playing with that
extension blog diaz center flow and tensor
player are not the same it is true one is
based on the other and tensor floyd  and it is
precisely the javascript library
that allows us to develop and train
machine learning models the
golden model that we have talked about is the
moment using javascript the advantage
of doing it with javascript or the advantage
of tensions is that it allows us to do it
both on the side of the  client in the
browser as in a server by
night already has a catalog uex
already has a good catalog a
wide and extensive catalog of already
existing models that we can simply
use import and start working
with them plus teach these same
models it is not necessary that  we
develop our own models
that are remembered at the beginning, it was not
exactly the objective of the talk,
but we did play a little with it with this
library because what we do is if
these models already exist, we can
teach them at our convenience and in the
end what it does  the library is
to determine a percentage of precision
that is precisely this prediction
that we have been talking about that is
rodríguez extension and returning to the subject
of the talk javascript has arrived at this
precisely and libraries like
this allow us to introduce ourselves and play
with it with the theme  and the concepts of
machine learning without the need
to be experts in the
field and that is what is interesting
about web keys, how far it has come and
how we can implement it today
in situations that we did
not see several years ago  how
possible
then is this example that I
shared with you of Negro Lake and the chip
implanted in animals, wow,
it is an example
for me that is somewhat unrealistic in
terms of my abilities, but
it is something that is already there that we were able to do
see and appreciate we are going to make a little
game something much simpler than that
through tension flow and that is what
tensor player does is prepare the
raw data I am going to emphasize again
the learning process we have
raw data what  What we do is define a
candidate model, how the
words that begin with the letter are pronounced, or
surely we hit the
pronunciation of two or three words, that
will be our first candidate, and
eventually we will have more words, more words,
more words, and what we are
doing.  it's nothing more than
training our candidate model
as we get more words the model
will get a little more accurate and more
accurate more accurate until
eventually it can cover most of
the scenarios there will be data that doesn't but that's what it's all
about  a prediction will not
cover all cases
because it is not about that it does not go
there try to define a model that
applies to the vast majority of cases
of course there will be aberrations that if they
leave the model and it is valid that is what it
refers to  With the percentage of loss that
a model can have, eventually we are going
to validate it and we are going to develop
our own predictions with these
same ones with these same models we have
a data input we run the model
and that produces a data output
that is a percentage of  precision that
this model can have now I am going to
make a small backup here to
explain the issue of tension over tensor
flow and why it bears the name or the
origin of the name of this library,
although tensor as such is a
mathematical term and  I said at the beginning I
am not a mathematician who can explain
this
if we try to see it in a
practical example or something landing the most at my
level of knowledge let's think for
example of a ship that goes in the
ocean and the tensor would come
representing that  What is, for example,
the flow of water, how it goes
against the movement of the boat,
when there is a collision, a force does not go
in the opposite direction, precisely from there,
the shape of a wedge
that what it does is push the water  in
a direction that allows it to continue
advancing and that is that conversion of the
vector of the direction of the water to the direction
of the boat itself and there is that
conversion factor that pushes the water in
the different directions
that is what can be determined by a
tensor and a  tensor speaking in
data structure is precisely that
value that a data input takes,
transforms it, converts it and produces a
different output and that value can either be a
scalar number or it can be in
most cases we are talking about
an array a  data matrix that
matrix is ​​what is known as a tensor and
it is the one that gives rise to the name of the
flow tension library again I am not
looking for how to explain the term as such
because I cannot understand it but
landing the examples that is what
a tensor refers to  It is that matrix or that
data structure that allows me to bring
an input,
transform it and produce a
different output and with this make a
prediction that the production will
simply be a percentage of certainty
about the output that said model is giving me
with this in  mind we can do
some exercises tensor flow is
a library that you can install we
are talking about and those who can
install through nm or can
consume through a cdn making a
reference to the online library
simply what we are going to
to do is define, well, work on a
couple of examples. The first thing I
would like to show you on the screen is a
small play ground where what it does is
precisely show
graphically the learning process that
our model is leading to with the
eventual input of data.  what
we want is an output and the
intermediary layer, which is what will
allow us to process or transform this
data here, what I would expect, for
example, if my data input goes
both vertically and
horizontally, what I expect to see is a
prediction where you can locate
the blue data in the center in a circular way
while the outer
data is amber or
yellow or mustard as you like to call it
and this will change depending on the
same
data processing example if my
data input were not  both directions
maybe a purely
linear vertical categorization the model is
separating them in this way it is
categorizing them in such a way that half
determines it as the blue dots the
other half determines it as the
amber or mustard yellow dots why
is this important  or what it represents
depending on the data input
depending on the neurons we have
to process this data is the
prediction that will give us towards the
towards the output is this platform
allows us to play with these predictions and
it varies depending on what
we want and  get eventually
I repeat there are going to be points that can
get out of the model thinking that there is a
blue dot on this side
absolutely nothing happens it is a lost data and
it goes out of the same model but the
percentage is still
quite high what the bookstore does  it is
precisely to generate predictions and
again it is a percentage where
if it has 100%, it is that it is sure
of the output that it is going to give us,
however, well, this is a mere playground,
what interests me is rather to see
playing a little  from the library and
we go with tensor flow we have
more than some examples that we can have
to train already existing models for
example what we can do in this
case is to teach the machine about I don't
know how to differentiate a vehicle or a car
differentiate
a plane by  For example, what are we going to
do through the camera? The only thing we are going to
do is define
two models, teach the computer
that one is a vehicle and that the other is
an airplane, and in the end, depending on one or the
other, it  What we are going to tell her
is that she must decide if it is an
airplane or a vehicle, maybe it is a I was
telling them, it is a demo, a much
simpler example than predicting how
an animal is walking, but
we have to start with something, this is my  data entry
now we are going to allow the
computer to do this cycle that we had been
talking about where it receives
the data it
learns with each of the images that
I have captured it is learning we
are teaching the computer to
differentiate between one object and another and
when  I'm ready when I say that I've
processed all the images I've already read
all the words in English that
begin with the letter o and I already have a
model ready that can tell you how to
pronounce a word that begins with the
letter o or differentiate between one object and
another  when I show him a new
image then what he's going to do is
say ok
I'm a few percent sure I'm
100% sure this is a car and
I'm 100% sure this is a
plane and I can be changing  one with
another
allowing the library to define what
is the percentage of certainty that
our model that has just learned has
thanks to the images that we were
capturing the integration process that we
have already discussed before and continues
to capture data simply to say
this is a plane this  It is a vehicle and
how is it there are different applications,
for example, you can download one on your cell phone
that will tell you if the
photo you are taking is a hot dog or
not, it has been that simple, or you can capture
an image and it will tell you  if it is something
that they could hug or not, depending on
how soft this image may
appear, or if it is a dog or a cat,
etc., etc. and of course there
will be differences between certain
entries, for example if we tell them
maybe  an image that tells me if it is a
dog or not and while he is learning
I show him in the image of a
Newfoundland for example the same and he tells me
that it is a bear, the best thing is not to tell me that it is
a dog but the more images
he has
The more you will learn and the more precise it
will become like this example. There are
many others. I invite you to play
Pacman. I don't know how cool it is,
putting images like the ones
we did.
the control
to go down left to right the
library exists there are a large number of
demos that you can run
through tension flow and the important thing here is to
understand the main concepts
that we have been talking about that is, we
know the learning process
we know that  there is the attention
cloud library and that is we can work and
create our own application with it
use models that already exist we can
train these models and eventually
say ok that dog is
such a breed or let's think why not in
applications such as a lost
puppy capture the image of the  puppy
through the camera of your cell phone
search the different social networks
to see who has reported a
puppy with
similar characteristics for example and
eventually say this is where it is
with pleasure in fact on my part on my
part we are fine  In time, it would be, it would be
everything and I invite you to ask yourself a
couple of questions, well, a question and a
challenge script, let's
all play with the library, this was
a very simple demo, why not play and
take this to the next level?
That would be one and two would be to answer the
following question, how can
machine learning be useful to us in
our day-to-day life or in our
businesses so that we can implement
machine or link in our
businesses knowing the concepts that
we have just learned and knowing the
library  that will allow us to
reach levels that we had not
considered before through javascript I
leave you with this question and please go
ahead if you have any doubts I am at your
service I hope you have found it a
topic of interest I did not expect
that from here  we would come out experts in the
subject but if we do a short
introduction to machine learning with
javascript I hope you
liked it